>> HI THERE.
THE COMEY MEMOS ARE OUT.
YOU KNOW WHO IS HAPPY ABOUT IT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ONE MEMO REVEALS THAT THE
PRESIDENT EARLY ON ENDORSED
LOOKING INTO ANY WRONGDOING BY
PEOPLE IN HIS CAMPAIGN.
COMEY TRUMP TOLD HIM IF THERE
WAS AN ASSOCIATE OF HIS CAMPAIGN
THAT DID SOMETHING, IT WOULD BE
GOOD TO FIND THAT OUT.
HE HAD NOT DONE ANYTHING AND
HOPED I WOULD FIND A WAY TO GET
OUT THAT WE WERE NOT
INVESTIGATING HIM.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THE NOTE
SHOWED CLEARLY THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION AND NO OBSTRUCTION AND
THAT THE FBI DIRECTOR LEAKED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
COMEY CLAIMED HE DOESN'T DO
SNEAKY THINGS AND DOESN'T LEAK
OR DO WEASEL MOVES.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> HE WENT ON TO LEAK HIS MEMO
AND ADMIT HE DID IT.
>> I KNOW WHEN I CREATED SOME OF
THEM THEY WERE CLASSIFIED.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF THAT
GROUP WOULD TESTIFY.
TRYING TO FORCE THE CREATION OF
A SPECIAL COUNCIL.
WHY?
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THE DEPARTMENT
AS CURRENTLY SUPERVISED WOULD
NOT BE AGGRESSIVE ENOUGH TO
SERVE PROCESS TO GET THE TAPES.
>> BECAUSE JEFF SESSIONS IS TOO
WEAK?
>> HE RESCUED HIMSELF.
THERE WAS A NEW DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHOM I DID NOT HAVE
CONFIDENCE.
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE.
THERE WERE LOTS OF DISCUSSION IN
PUBLIC ABOUT APPOINTING A
SPECIALITY.
>> THE WATCH DOG AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS INVESTIGATING
COMEY'S HANDLING OF THE MEMOS.
KIMBERLY, WE ARE LAUGHING ABOUT
THE LINE WEASEL MOVE.
BUT IT'S NOT FUNNY BECAUSE WE
HAD'S RUN DOWN OF SOME OF THE
VIOLATIONS HE MIGHT BE LOOKING
AT FOR LEAKING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND IT'S SERIOUS.
>> FOR SURE.
IT'S COMPELLING.
NO PROOF OF COLLUSION OR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
HE JUST TORPEDOED MUELLER.
READ THE MEMOS TO SHOW BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT THAT THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT DIRECT ANYBODY
IN TERMS OF COLLUSION OR TRYING
TO OBSTRUCT ANYTHING WHATSOEVER.
IT HELPS THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT TODAY
SAID I WAS VINDICATED.
THIS HELPED HIS SIDE.
WHAT COMEY SINGLING, I DON'T
KNOW.
HE COMPROMISED ANYTHING THAT
MUELLER COULD HAVE BEEN TRIED TO
BE COOKING UP.
NOW IT'S FRAUGHT WITH
INCONSISTENCIES AND PROBLEMS IN
TERMS OF OTHER WITNESSES HE
MIGHT BE TRYING TO CALL.
ALL OF THE STATEMENTS THAT COMEY
MADE ON THE BOOK TOUR.
THE STATEMENTS IN THE BOOK AND
PRIOR TO THE RELEASE OF THE
BOOK.
THE COMPLICATIONS WITH LORETTA
LYNCH.
A BIG STIRRED UP MESS COURTESY
OF THE FORMER HEAD OF THE FBI.
>> RIGHT.
COMEY IS COLLAPSING.
HE SAID HE DOESN'T LEAK AND THEN
HE LEAKS AND HE SAID THAT
McCABE, TOTAL PROFESSIONAL,
GREAT GUY.
YOU CAN TRUST HIM.
HE DOESN'T LEAK EITHER.
THEN McCABE LEAKS AND LIES ABOUT
IT.
THE TOP TWO GUYS AT THE FBI NOT
LOOKING TOO GOOD.
>> YES, WHO I FEEL REALLY BAD
FOR THE RESISTANCE.
>> HA.
>> I DO.
THEY EXPECT A HORSE FOR
CHRISTMAS BUT THEY GET A
HAMSTER.
IN THIS CASE A DEAD HAMSTER.
THE LEFT HASN'T BEEN THIS
DISAPPOINTED SINCE THE BERLIN
WALL FELL.
THEIR OBSESSION TO UNSEAT A
PRESIDENT CREATED A CARMICK
POLTERGEIST.
I HAVE AN EXERCISE FOR EVERYBODY
PERSON IN THE MEDIA, THOSE ON
CNN AND MSNBC.
OVER THE WEEKEND TAKE 10 MINUTES
TO YOURSELF AND TRY TO ANSWER
YOURSELF THIS ONE QUESTION:
WHAT IS THE END GAME TO ALL OF
THIS COVERAGE ABOUT COMEY,
STORMY AND COLLUSION?
IT JUST FOR AN ADULT FILM STAR?
IS IT TRYING TO UNCOVER SOME
SECRET CONSPIRACY YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR 2 YEARS BUT HAVE
NOT FOUND A THING?
ARE YOU JUST TRYING TO GET RID
OF A PRESIDENT?
IF THAT'S THE CASE, YOU ARE
ACTUALLY HURTING THE COUNTRY AND
HURTING EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY
OVER A PERSONAL VENDETTA.
>> THEY DON'T CARE BECAUSE IT'S
POLITICAL.
>> AND BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
EMOTIONAL TRIGGERED BY AN
ELECTION.
I DON'T THINK WHEN PEOPLE ARE
REPORTING ON THIS STUFF, THEY
ASK WHAT IS THE END GAME?
WHAT DO I WANT OUT OF THIS?
OTHER THAN 10 MINUTES OF GOOD
RATINGS.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE IS NOW SUING TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN, AND JARED KUSHNER AND
DON JR. AND RUSSIA AND
WIKI-LEAKS FOR MAKING HILLARY
LOSE.
WHAT KIND OF FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT
IS THIS?
>> IT'S THE LAST DYING PRESS OF
THE RESISTANCE.
THEY BLAME TRUMP FOR EVERYTHING
THEY DID.
WHICH WAS COLLUDE WITH THE
RUSSIANS AND COME UP WITH THIS
DOSSIER THAT WAS PAID FOR.
COMEY DIDN'T JUST SAY I AM A
LEAKER.
HE SAID I AM NOT A WEASEL.
I AM A STRAIGHT SHOOTER.
HE IS IN THE OFFICE WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT WOULD A STRAIGHT SHOOTER
SAY WHEN HE BRINGS UP THE
DOSSIER.
HEY, THIS IS A DOSSIER ABOUT YOU
AND PROSTITUTES AND A STRAIGHT
SHOOTER WOULD SAY IT WAS PAID
FOR BY HILLARY AND THE DNC.
HE DIDN'T.
HE IS NOT A STRAIGHT SHOOTER.
THE END GAME IS TO NOT JUST
POTENTIALLY IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT BUT TO DISSPIRIT TRUMP
VOTERS.
IT'S TO MAKE US FEEL TO PULL THE
POLL NUMBERS DOWN.
I LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT'S POLL
NUMBERS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HOW HIGH THEY
ARE CONSIDERING HOW MUCH WAS
THROWN AT HIM.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> SOMEONE HAS HIM AT 90.
>> LAST TIME IT WAS UP TO 99.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> REALLY QUICK THE QUESTION GOT
DNC.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST BONEHEAD
MOVES I HAVE SEEN IN A LONG
TIME.
DO THEY NOT UNDERSTAND THERE IS
DISCOVERY ON BOTH SIDES?
THIS IS A TREASURE TROVE OF
INFORMATION COMING TO THE OTHER
SIDE.
SHOW ME WHAT YOU HAVE.
SHOW ME ALL OF YOUR DOCUMENTS.
THIS WILL MUDDY THE WATERS
BEFORE THE MID-TERM ELECTIONS
AND CREATE PROBLEMS FOR THE
REPUBLICANS BUT THEY CREATED
PROBLEMS FOR THEMSELVES.
>> OUR RESIDENT DEMOCRATIC HERE.
JAMES COMEY ADMITTED HE DIDN'T
TELL DONALD TRUMP THAT HILLARY
CLINTON PAID FOR THE DOSSIER AND
HE DOESN'T KNOW IF THE DOSSIER
IS LEGITIMATE OR NOT.
I THINK HE SAID SOMETHING LIKE
IT'S UNLIKELY BUT POSSIBLE.
LET'S HEAR WHAT HE SAID.
>> WHAT YOU ARE ASKING ME ABOUT
NOW WHAT DID I SAY WHAT I SAID
WHEN I WAS ASKED IF THE RUSSIANS
HAD DEROGATORY INFORMATION ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I SAID IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> WHAT IS INTERESTING IN THE
COMEY MEMOS.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
NOT JUST THE SALACIOUS DETAILS
ABOUT THE HOTEL ROOM IN MOSCOW.
IN THE COMEY MEMOS HE BRIEFED
THE PRESIDENT THAT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CONFIRMED
PARTS OF THE DOSSIER.
HE DOESN'T DETAIL THAT IN THE
COMEY MEMOS.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT.
>> LET'S FIND OUT.
HE MAKES CLEAR THERE IS
INTELLIGENCE TO BACK UP OTHER
PIECES OF THE DOSSIER.
IT'S NOT UNSUBSTANTIATED.
>> THERE IS A LINK TO MOSCOW?
>> THERE WAS A REPORT THAT COHEN
MIGHT HAVE BEEN IN PRAGUE.
>> WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL --
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT TRUMP
COLLUDED WITH THE RUSSIAN IN
THIS CAMPAIGN?
YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> I BELIEVE THAT MEMBERS CLOSE
TO THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
REACHED OUT TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND OFFERED HELP.
WE KNOW THAT.
THAT'S BEEN PUBLICLY DISCUSSED.
I BELIEVE THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WAS WILLING TO WORK
WITH THEM WHETHER TO RELEASE
HILLARY'S EMAILS.
WHAT DONALD TRUMP KNEW OR DID I
DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S WHAT ROBERT MUELLER IS
LOOKING INTO.
THERE WERE MEMBERS OF THE
CAMPAIGN WILLING TO MEET WITH
RUSSIAN AND DISCUSS HILLARY
EMAILS.
THAT'S A FACT THAT'S BEEN
REPORTED.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ANSWERS 2
THROUGH 5 ARE.
THAT'S WHAT MUELLER IS LOOKING
INTO.
COMEY IS ONLY A SMALL PART OF
THAT.
THE LARGER INVESTIGATION COMEY
IS NOT THE END-ALL AND BE ALL.
>> LET'S STICK TO THE FACT.
THERE WAS NO CONTACT THAT SHOWS
COLLUSION WHATSOEVER.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> I KNOW HILLARY PAID FOR
RUSSIANS USED IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> EXACTLY.
THEY PUT A FANCY NAME ON IT AND
CALLED IT A DOSSIER.
>> BYRON YORK FROM THE
WASHINGTON EXAMINER HAD A GREAT
PIECE TODAY.
YOU ARE THE FBI DIRECTOR AND
YOUR FIRST MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT DONALD TRUMP.
YOU GO I HAVE THIS SALACIOUS
INFORMATION ON YOU.
DONALD TRUMP PROBABLY THOUGHT HE
WAS BEING BLACK MAILED.
HE SAID THAT TO A REPORTER.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA
TO LEAD WITH THIS DIRTY DOSSIER
IN YOUR FIRST MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT?
MAYBE THAT'S WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID HE NEED LOYALTY HERE
BECAUSE HE FELTLY COULD NOT
TRUST JAMES COMEY.
WE ARE FINDING OUT FROM THE MEMO
IT WAS PRESSURE FROM CNN.
LET'S SHOW THAT ON THE SCREEN
HERE THAT LED TO JAMES COMEY
BRIEFING THE PRESIDENT.
MEDIA LIKE CNN HAD THEM AND WERE
LOOKING FOR A NEWS HOOK.
I EXPLAINED WHY I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT THAT HE KNOW ABOUT IT.
I EXPLAINED THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS WE TOLD HIM WAS THAT CNN
IN PARTICULAR WAS TELLING US
THEY WERE ABOUT TO RUN WITH IT."
THEN THE STORY LEAKS TO CNN A
FEW HOURS LATER.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T TRUST SHADY JAMES.
>> FOLLOW THE SNAIL TRAIL.
THIS IS LAID OUT FOR YOU.
UNBELIEVABLE.
HE SHOULD HAVE GONE INTO A NICE
MEETING AND TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT.
IT'S OFF PUTTING THE FIRST TIME.
WHY ARE YOU BRINGING THIS UP TO
ME.
IF  I AM THINKING COMEY IS
TRYING TO CATCH HIM OFF GUARD.
LOOKING TO TRY TO HOOK HIM
BEFORE HE HAS EXCHANGES, HE IS
GOING AFTER HIM.
A SPECIFIC INTENT AND WHOSE TEAM
HE WAS PLAYING FOR.
HIS WHOLE TEAM WAS IN UNISON
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT FROM DAY
ONE.
WHY DID CNN HAVE IT?
IF THERE IS COLLUSION YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LOOK TO RUSSIA TO FIND
OUT.